the two-minute rule was suggested by  author james clear and aims to inspire  action taking there are two parts in the  two-minute row part one is if it takes  less than two minutes then do it now  this piece of advice is suggested by  david allen in his best-selling book  getting things done if you take a minute  to consider how many things we put off  that could be done in 2 minutes or less  you will be amazed part 2 is when you  start a new habit it should take less  than two minutes to begin with it when  it comes to habit performing tasks the  most difficult part is the takeoff that  small time frame in the beginning of the  task until you get immersed in it and  enter flow state the idea behind this  rule is to force yourself to stay in the  task for at least two minutes even if  you find it extremely difficult to do so  these two minutes are enough to get your  mind from a passive state to an active  state once it gets into that state  immersion ensues